And wall dean responds and the orthodox
Muslim. I'm warning you guys against
them. I am warning you against these two
people. I'm making catch. I've got I've
got off the hide. I'm being straight up.
I'm warning you guys against them. You
know why?
Everything you own from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die. That's what
Allah says.
You are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves. Brothers and
sisters, masid Norway, the one that we
built is looking to another masid around
the area of Norway. Subhan Allah. Where
there's so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This masid is only
$500,000. And any donation that you give
will go towards your because when you
enter that grave, nobody's going to
remember you except Allah subhanaa tala.
So make it count, brothers and sisters,
and donate towards this message,
inshallah, a new project that's only
$500,000. And believe me, if every
single one of us give £1, £10, £100,
£1,000, that's going to be something you
will never regret on your makyama. And
everything that you lose is going to
perish and go, but your deeds and your
makyama are not. Donate to the link
inshallah. Let's get to the video.
Asalam alaikum brothers and sisters and
dear friends. Hope you guys are well
inshallah. Um when I talk about these
issues guys, people call me Ali drama
and says save the drama for your mama.
Now I don't believe it's drama when I
talk about this stuff. I don't Allah
subhanaa is my witness. I don't got my
way. I don't want to do it. But I get
really irritated and annoyed and and and
and most of the times when I do these
videos, it's not that someone's wronged
me. It's rather that someone has wronged
others. And wall I'll be honest with
you. If there's anything that I would
want to be remembered for the sake of
Allah is to defend the honor of other
Muslims. because if anything, Muslims do
what? Attack the Muslims, degrade them,
insult them. And that's exactly what's
happened. Now, I've decided not to
mention the name. It's very obvious. I
just don't want to go into that. I've
privately messaged the brother. I spoke
to him and made my um opinions very,
very clear to him. Why? And before I get
to that though in when it comes to
brother Libyano Orthodox Muslim the
orthodox Muslim and brother Dean
responds and wall I'll be honest with
you exactly what it says in the title I
have worked with them uh in the sense
where I've studied underneath them
alhamdulillah they are much younger than
me and I am absolutely proud I don't
have this ego thing of they are younger
than me and they're upcoming and I don't
may Allah subhanaa tala protect us all
yes anybody that serves the dean and if
you're a YouTuber like a big Ali da
YouTuber like me and a newcomer comes
and I have a like oh you know this is a
disease of the heart and
of the because I genuinely mean this I
know I'm see this a lot and shazam tells
me Ali be easy with taking off etc
responds and the orthodox Muslim I'm
warning you guys against them I am
warning you against these two people I'm
making catch I've got I've gone off the
head I'm being straight I'm warning you
guys against him. You know why? These
guys are lethal, bro. I've studied with
them, bro. Let me tell you something.
They're beautiful brothers. I've seen
nothing but goodness in them. I've seen
nothing but softness in them. May Allah
bless and preserve them. May Allah
forgive them for what we don't know
about them and may Allah make them
better than what we think of them. So, I
want to be careful with my praise as
well. I don't want to overpraise them.
May Allah protect them. They are
brothers. If there's anything that I
will tell tell them and anyone in the da
scene intentions. Yes. And for me
personally, I say always brothers in the
da make dua. Allah protects you from the
fna of woman. Okay? Now, other than
that, wall and I'm not trying to
overpraise them. They're human beings.
Anyone that has loyalty to Allah and his
messenger, I'm loyal with them. I have
no loyalty to anyone, not to Liiano, not
to respond, not to Daniel, not to Jake,
not to Fared, not to Hajim, whoever you
want, whoever want name it. Anyone that
goes against that, we should all have a
problem. Even if it's me, if I go
against those principles. So these
brothers, mashallah, when it comes to
argumentations, the research that they
do, the effort that they put through,
I'm so sorry. We should in the da be
happy that the upcoming generation, me
and Muhammad, we are so happy. And even
Zishan, we are so happy that these kind
of brothers are upcoming and they are
lethal. And I warn you against them. And
who am I warning? The Christians and the
enemies of Islam. Because this next
generation are lethal, bro. They are
cold as ice. They are making your lives
hell. That's the reason why I disagree
so much with a brother who's come out
and calling people who have given their
life to the dean like Ahmed Dat Zakin
that the arguments suck. Yes. With all
due respect or this person we don't know
if he's a Muslim or Liiano or Dean
response is doing it for the fame and
money. Excuse me. How do we know? How do
you know that? Aki, how do you know
that? I am sorry. I've been told not to
do this video. This is my own take and
I'm doing it. I'm so sorry. You know
why? Because it is wrong. Someone and
the group of brothers who are serving
the dean. Let's suppose some are doing
it for them. I don't care, bro. I I
don't see that. I don't know the hearts.
I judge from what's apparent. And
judging from what's apparent is what
these brothers are trying their best.
And if they're doing it for the wrong
reasons, including myself, Allah will
use us for his dean and we will end up
in the hell fire. May Allah protect us.
So the reason I'm doing this video is to
say guys, brother Dean responds,
"Brother Liby, I know, alhamdulillah,
the upcoming brothers in the YouTube
scene are doing absolutely fantastic.
May Allah protect them against arrogance
and ill intentions and doing it for the
wrong reasons, which I'm I reject that
they're doing that. There's nothing that
they've shown that doing that." And I,
like I said before, I'm not saying
because we obviously have to be careful
about overpraising people. So I'm very
careful. From what we see, we see
nothing but goodness. They serve the
religion and it should be a warning to
all of the enemies of Islam. They are
making your life hell and we are right
behind our brothers till the day we die.
As long as they are on the huck, we are
behind them. Okay? And if they come off
it and if I come off it, I want them to
correct me and I will correct them. But
for that brother, for the brother who is
going and putting them in a category A,
B, C, D, E, F, G, whatever it is for
that matter, I believe I'm right at the
bottom of that category. And I don't
mean this in any humble ways at all. I
think I should be zed. Yes, believe me.
I believe I'm the least knowledgeable in
the da scene and the most problematic
probably in the da scene. Okay, may
Allah forgive me. But let me tell you,
if I was to categorize who is causing
more harm to the da with these moves, I
will put that brother who's doing these
videos right at the top. You are giving
ammunition and saying that apparently
Liiano or Philos got destroyed by God
logic. Brother, I am the least
knowledgeable. God logic triangle
square. Yes, you saw what happened.
Absolute idiotic He's probably
watching this. The guy believes you can
have a triangle square. God logic. Dog
logic. Dog at least a dog logic believes
in one master. Serves one master. He's
no logic. Liiano destroyed him on
multiple occasions. Yes. And we are
behind our brother Libiano. And Dean
responds, "Let's make that categorically
clear for anybody that is coming for
them. I don't give a damn who you are,
bro." Okay? You have no right to come
and tarnish the da. Okay. And the
brothers in the dawa who are trying
their best, habibi. Okay. May Allah
forgive you for this move. We don't know
what the issue is, but I just want to
make this categorically clear that
you're not going to come here, bro. For
whatever reason you have or whatever
you're going through, may Allah make it
easy for you, bro. And I've messaged you
on private message as well. So, anything
I'm saying here is no different to what
I said there, Habib. Yeah. Okay.
Genuinely disappointed, genuinely upset
and hurt. But I just want to say
alhamdulillah brothers are doing a
fantastic work and they have the support
of their brothers here in the UK and
around the world and whoever it is for
that matter. Okay, anyone that comes and
tries to tarnish the da'wah and tries to
throw mud to brothers who are doing good
work and for those who have given their
life who have passed away and you say
their arguments suck, I'm not going to
say nothing, bro. May Allah subhana wa
ta'ala guide you and allow you to
understand the mistake that you're
doing. And like I said before, guys, may
Allah subhanaa tala forgive me for
anything that I've said that is wrong. I
don't mean anything hurtful. Even this
brother who was doing this wall, I have
nothing but love for you. I'm just
genuinely disappointed that you are
going after me. You've done nothing to
me. You've done Did you say anything to
me? Nothing. But bro, what you're doing
is wrong. Please, I hope you retract
this and fix your ways because one thing
that I will say cuz we was talking about
judging from a worse apparent. Yeah,
bro. I see arrogance. I see some kind of
I can totally wrong. Arrogance of one
I'm better than thy thy more holy than
thou. Yes. Okay. Wallah this is
dangerous. Be very careful that you are
not holy than no one everyone else. You
are you're not someone that knows
better. Okay. Alhamdulillah. You are a
revert just like myself. Okay. Please I
ask Allah to protect you and allow you
to come to your senses inshallah. That's
all I want to say. Sorry for the rant
guys but it really really really hurt me
and I just I just people told me not to
do video but I can't I couldn't help
myself. Till next time. amlaykum.
May Allah bless and preserve all the
brothers in the dao and sisters who are
serving his dean and trying to make
Allah's calam the highest including our
brother who's wronged other brothers.
May Allah allow him to come back. He is
a great asset. One thing I do want to
say as well before I forget uh the
brother at hand that we're talking about
who's doing this. He has so much
potential. He is a I would say he is a
gem in the da or should I say was yes I
hope he can come back. He's got so much
to offer and so many people have learned
through him. Don't ruin this, bro. Do
not ruin this. Yes. By coming and
saying, "Oh, this person took my style.
Habib, it doesn't belong to you." Allah
gave you that, bro. If anyone comes and
takes it, who cares? If someone comes
and calls himself, I don't know,
something da who cares what I'm going to
say. Oh, it's mine. Yeah. No, it doesn't
belong to you. It belongs to Allah
subhanaa tala. Bro, I ask Allahh to
allow you to be used like that from us
that we can learn from you. But if you
turn around, bro, and do this kind of
stuff. Subhan Allah. May Allah protect
us inshallah.
Everything you own from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die. That's why
Allah says
you are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves. Brothers and
sisters, masid Norway, the one that we
built is looking to another masid around
the area of Norway. Subhan Allah. Where
there's so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This masjid is only
$500,000 and any donation that you give
will go towards your because when you
enter that grave nobody's going to
remember you except Allah subhanaa tala.
So make it count brothers and sisters
and donate towards this message
inshallah a new project that's only
$500,000 and believe me if every single
one of us give £1,10,000
that's going to be something you will
never regret on your makayama and
everything that you lose is going to
perish and go. But your deeds and your
makama are not. Donate to the link
inshallah.